returning back to tiger belly because
you said uh kalila basically started it
what's the origin story of tiger belly
you know when i met her
oh by the way for people listening in
case you somehow don't know tiger belly
is a podcast you do it's an amazing
podcast you also do uh bad friends with
uh andrew centino yeah so on thank you
so much for the plug appreciate it i
don't know it's kante it's not the plug
can i plug other things though since
we're doing it uh sure sure okay that's
your uh i'm on a show called okay that's
enough thank you so um
what what's the name of the show you're
on i want a couple of couple shows oh
it's good for you netflix it's no
okay i'm on
sex in the city the sex in the city yeah
i'm on reservation dogs
it's an fx show
wait sex in the city is not a joke
no i am actually on sex in the city what
are they rebooting the show they did
okay it's called and just like that sex
in the city oh and you're on it yeah is
this not this is not a joke you can
google it okay
you know what i mean who do you play
i play uh a podcaster on it on the show
sarah jessica parker's carrie
has a podcast and i'm her podcast
partner oh got it perfect beautiful but
then but i'm also now they've my
storyline anyway it's fine do you sleep
with somebody on there i am married on
the show yeah they showed my i married
to a young lady on it yeah yeah
it felt like it felt like it you know
because you don't think doing it
i look around going are you sure i'm
supposed to be on this
you know i mean i do feel that but
lo and behold i'm on it yeah you are
so um i started this way so you know my
friend david cho
you know him he's an artist
he used to have a podcast right
called dvd asa
and um
he used to have me on it and then kalila
started doing it
and then when dvdsa ended
kalila was just like let's start our own
and i was like nah it's not gonna work
so she goes well fine i'm gonna just do
it on my own then
so she went and bought the equipment
and we were living in a condo at the
time in hollywood and she um
would do them on her own
she did probably three on her own
and one day i was watching television
the door was open to the podcast room
and
i looked turned around and she was
literally like this did she we had a
table like this with she had the mic and
all that stuff and she was doing this
she was like slumped over
like this
and i just kind of went [ __ ] it
so i walked in there and go all right
let's just do one yeah
and that was that's how it started and
then chemistry was there immediately
well i already knew that she could do it
because of dvdsa right so i already knew
that she had the skill set it's you know
you know it's just all about even in
this conversation that you and i had
today right
there are gaps of like oh what else are
we talking about right yeah right or
like i don't know what direction right
and it's all about the old improv rule
adding information
even if you don't know what you're gonna
say just fill the dead space with
something
like so if right now if we had some
stuff we stopped talking about something
like
like when i asked you did you grow up in
russia or ukraine right was one of those
dead spaces where i was just like let's
just throw it out there see where this
goes right
and she has that ability to fill that
dead space with information that's all
you need right
and um she gets it in that way so it's
like when we um
you know started doing it
at dvdsa i just knew that she had the
skill set so when we started doing it
for tiger belly
it was a given you know you know she can
do it i've had girlfriends that wouldn't
be able to do it what what what are you
doing
you know you have the skill set
you know you're a sciencey guy you spent
all night long you know i mean
you know i mean you know doing whatever
you're [ __ ] doing right but you have
this innate ability to do it
right and i think it's a talent
do you think it's a talent
no do you think it's do you think you
have talent
what are you doing
i know what you're doing not adding
information i know what you're doing
that's a good pit it's a good thing i
kept doing it and you kept filling the
space it's quite interesting yeah that
is true huh because you're yes ending
yourself which is great the improv thing
that's really impressive can i ask you a
question sure have you ever had a guest
on
that didn't add information and then you
had to keep doing it
yeah yeah
but it's part of the magic too and
sometimes i feel like uh
they were actually giving me a gift of
silence
and i was stepping on it like for
example i had a conversation with jocko
you know jocko willink
and every question i would ask him in
the beginning and i'm now better friends
with him
it was the first time we met in that
conversation and i would ask him these
long questions of mumble and meander and
so on and he would answer with yes or no
and that's it yeah
and then but he'd do it in a strong like
viking-like way
and i kept i kept
uh trying to
go full like
uh bobby lee style of create chaos and
just keep talking talking and so on
as opposed to i think he was inviting me
more for the stoic type of
silence
short sentences that kind of
conversation so i [ __ ] that up i
believe uh but yeah there's uh
that not the adding information part but
the adding chemistry part
or something it's usually ego
where
where people don't realize there's a
magic to be found between two humans
like genuine it's like a first date like
that to truly listen to each other and
to do the yes and thing
and have fun with it
when you have this energy i'm way too
important
for this conversation
that the yeah the information might be
there but the chemistry is not so you
have to remember that a lot of the
podcasts i've done are
like technical yeah and so
you could still say a lot of stuff about
like what what the this project or
whether it's physics or robotics or
biology you could say informational
stuff but the the excitement the magic
is not there
but i often blame myself because like if
i'm excited
they'll be excited i've learned this so
i'm learning i'm not allowed to have
like a
uh bored face which
mine my face is naturally looks bored
but on the inside i'm excited yeah it's
a it might be a russian thing i don't
know it's not can i tell you why you're
not boring your face all right
because um you have crow's feet
oh this thing yeah that was the thing
yeah and the reason why you have crow's
feet
is you smile a lot yeah yeah you're very
expressive i know white dudes i don't
trust white dudes yeah right with no
crow's feet
right because that means they don't that
they're not you know me accessing that
part of their you know i mean face yeah
you know which is why i hate when um
this is an la thing especially yeah uh
women have talked to me but like botox
and they they hate the crow they they
hate not
me on themselves oh and they they hate
because it's all wrinkles and stuff like
that and to me it's like no that's where
the that's the magic magic it really is
yeah
uh so okay so the interesting thing
about tiger belly
is there's some weird like aesthetic to
it it's really unique it's not just good
it's also unique like in the way that
wes anderson films are unique like life
aquatic i don't know if you know those
films yeah i love those i mean they're
my favorite films yeah what is that what
is that
it it's not just the chemistry between
you and koala it's like
what is that can you can you put a
finger on it or is it just like
well it's it's essentially who i am i i
like i
that's what my all my houses have looked
like that
you know i mean like i've always been a
collector of
designer toys you know i mean i've
always been a collector of um kind of
weird artwork
um
yeah i've always been like that you know
i i like weird wallpaper like i'll get
instead of like going to a wallpaper
store what i'll do is i'll get artwork
that i like
from an artist like and go get the you
know get their approval
and go to a place and make wallpaper out
of their artwork
you know i mean you can like if i wanted
a lex friedman your face on my wall i
would ask for your permission and i
would probably put your face on a
gigantic wall like i would do stuff like
that that's awesome yeah but
can you
my point is is that i um
yeah it's essentially who i am on the
inside i guess in terms of like my
you know
i don't know but i don't really i've
never
i'm glad you said that because i never
even
thought about that
yeah he's just you know you just kind of
do it like this you know because all
your podcasts have this black
ominous thing yeah you're you know
you're you're wearing a black suit
you're you have a specific thing too
it's like but i don't i don't really
think people ask me like why do you wear
a suit i really don't i just feel good
in it yeah just who i am and the reason
why my podcast looks the way i do is
because i feel comfortable in that
environment
and it you know
like you
i don't try to think too much about what
i'm doing on tiger belly or even bad
friends right because when you start
thinking about it and go we should do
this segment and i should you know
do it this way or this podcast does it
this way so what you know
no i just show up i keep my mind open
and i do the best i can i add
information like we talked about and i
just keep talking right and i'm being i
try to be authentically myself
like right now you know i had this fear
when i was i was f i [ __ ] in your
[ __ ] bathroom man yeah because i was
so scared out of fear
yeah yeah and like you know i was like
kind of nervous because i
you know this whole week and it wasn't
anticipating coming here and i watched
the mark normand one i watched the
giannis one to see you know how
tonally and last night my girlfriend
just looked at me and just goes
just show up
yeah carla knows
who i am
dude you think that
first of all
let me ask you something yes you think i
have the day
you know how busy i am to
drive all the way over here to west
hollywood yeah to do your [ __ ] thing
why would i do that
yeah because we are a well aware of who
you are and we like you
thank you god we want you on ours yeah i
would love that i would love that as a i
mean that's that's that's the reason i'm
doing this is just to get in your pocket
you gotta get on it awesome
yeah it's funny because i i just
mentioned to you uh offline i got a
chance to talk to oliver stone
and he asked me this thing which is you
know how many um listeners does this
thing get all that kind of stuff and i
don't even pay attention to that so it's
like i just don't
a little bit though you do don't
i wrote extensions on my browsers where
i don't see the views the number of
views really yeah don't pay did you know
that like some of your youtube videos on
interviews and stuff have over a million
that i know i know i know like loosely
that
like
it bleeds through but it's it's not part
of my conscious like
um
thing i think about i'm very
i've just seen it destroy people's minds
where they're no longer thinking
creatively they're not
they uh don't feel good if something
they do doesn't get as much as attention
as they
thought it should it just can destroy
you
even though it's good it could be great
stuff you create that nobody everybody
ignores
but it was still great it is it is still
great
and uh sort of
letting that negatively affect your mind
is a i don't know i've seen it destroy
people so i'm very nervous about that
it's like that old saying
never living the results
it's like if i
if i podcast to make i'd like initially
honestly when i did tiger belly we made
no money for the first couple of years
like like not enough to put a dent i
couldn't buy anything like you know nice
or anything
um it was um side money you know i mean
i could buy some shoes once a month or
whatever right and
like i said before um
i was my career was in the [ __ ] right
so tiger billy wasn't like this is gonna
be the thing
you know i mean it was just something to
do with my girlfriend creatively you
know
and it just so happens
that it did do all these things for me
right um podcasting but um
yeah i never and still today i don't do
it for any of those things you know i do
it because um
it's fun
you